Let's look at the answer to our
quiz about the relationship between
the block size and the miss rate.
The question was,
which of the three Cs are really
reduced when the miss rate goes down?
Obviously, some misses
have been eliminated.
The question is which type
suffered the elimination.
Let's first look at
the compulsory misses.
If we have a small block size,
and this is our memory,
we'll bring in this block and
suffer a miss for the first time.
We bring in another block and
suffer a miss.
Now let's say we bring this block and
If the cache line size was
twice of what it is now,
then this second one would not have
been a miss because when we fetch
the first one, this second one would
have also been in the same cache block.
So as you can see, the increase in
the block size, assuming there is enough
locality, will result in
a reduction in compulsory misses.
Another way to look at this is to
note that we get the compulsory miss
when we access the block for
the very first time.
Well, if you have larger blocks,
there are fewer blocks, so
there are fewer blocks to access for the
very first time, and that will guarantee
a reduction in compulsory misses,
assuming there is any spatial locality.
Now let's look at capacity misses.
Let's say that the program is accessing
a relatively large array that doesn't
fit in the cache, and then,
we go back and access it again.
On the second set of accesses,
we're having capacity misses.
The first set of accesses were
compulsory misses because these blocks
were never in the cache.
Because they don't fit in the cache, by
the time we get to the end of the array,
the beginning of the array is
kicked out of the cache, and
now we're suffering capacity misses.
These blocks will be in
that infinite cache,
they are not in the cache
because it was not large enough.
But how many misses we will have for
this array depends on the block size.
WIth smaller blocks, the size array
will be occupying more blocks.
WIth larger blocks,
we will have fewer blocks.
The number of misses will be
equal to the number of blocks.
So as you can see,
if we increase the block size, and
our miss rate goes down because
there is plenty of spatial locality,
we are also reducing
the number of capacity misses.
And finally,
if we look at the conflict misses,
we can construct a similar example where
two blocks are kicking each other out,
and because,
each time we fetch a larger block,
if the block size goes up,
we will be having few conflict misses.
So the increase in block sizes
can improve all types of misses.
That is, it can reduce the number for
all three types of misses.
When we increase the block size,
the compulsory misses are almost
always going to go down.
The capacity misses
are going to go down,
as long as there is enough locality, and
the conflict misses are likely to
stay similar, but might go down.